N. WORKS IT
BACK O ANY ANGLEE
LANE, TAKE AWAY THE LANE, HOLD
IT.
AND BACK INTO THE LIGHTNING
ZONE
OPPORTUNITY ON THE TURNOVER.
THE TORORO
HAVE JUST JOINED US.
OFF OF THE STICK OF MARNER.
ELD
ATTEMP
BATTLE FOR THE PUCK.
THE ROAD.
>> Kenny: STAMKOS THE NEUTRAL
ZONE TRANSITION.
THE POINT ON THE ENTRY AND THEND
TRYING TO SHOOT IT OFF THE PAD.
>> Kenny: 3 ON 2 FOR THE
OFF OF THE STICK OF MORGAN
RIELLY, AND R
HOLL.
OFF OF THE STICK OF TAVARES. E.S
. FANS HAVE E  STAMKOS WITH IT.
HALF A MINUTE TO GO ON THE
POWER-PLAY FOR THE LIGHTNING.
HERE'S HED
INTO THE TAMPA BAY ZONE. THE LI
HERE COME THE DEFENSEMEN, WE
TALK ABOUT THE DEFENSEMEN BEING
ACTIVE FOR BOTH OF THESE TEAMS
AND NO  BLOCKED BY
LYUBUSHKIN.
KUCHEROV WITH THE PUCK  LEAVES
IT FOR STAMKOS
THE GREAT TRADITION OF HOCKEY
COMING IN 1 ON 2. NOW HOLL WITH
HE'S ABLE TO SERGACHEV  BUT
HOW AND
MAKES THE SHOT. THE LEAFS
ie: IT STARTED WITH
AUSTON MATTHEWS CAME IN TO HELP
OUT AND KEEPS  THE PLAY ALIVE.